the moment happened when i publicly said
i was no longer going to take a booster
and i gave my reasoning i've mentioned
this to you in private before but the
reasoning is as follows it's quite clear
for me and i don't see anybody how
anybody could find a problem with the
reasoning as i laid out on my social
feeds but also the history is all there
to check
you know i was injected in prison
now i'm a prisoner of conscience so by
definition anything done to me prison is
against my will
i don't know what they injected with me
till this day so i took a stance having
voluntarily taken
two jabs at the early stages when the
finally when the four-year-olds were
allowed to take it
because for me not that i trusted in
anything but for me being jabbed my
whole life by systems
uh a friend of mine once said it's like
you know when somebody's a rape victim
and and their definition of normal is
fluctuates i mean for me it was just
like oh let me get it out the way i did
it and i did it and i thought you know
what fine
but i'm never gonna
surrender the idea that lockdowns are
ever justified this was before the
mandates began
and then i went along and my critique
and my concern was only with lockdowns
and then suddenly you start learning
that people are saying no jab no job
and then they say there's a booster shot
that you have to take combined with no
jab no job and you're in a situation now
because the very definition of coercion
isn't i put a gun to your head when it
comes to medical procedures i don't need
a gun to your head coercion look at um
the universal declaration of human
rights and bioethics yeah i think is
article six if memory serves me
correctly and you look at the definition
of consent in there and there's
absolutely it states this explicitly
that no negative repercussion
should come at you for you refusing
consent that's what it means for you to
own your own consent that you're not
punished for exercising it otherwise
that's not consent by definition that's
coercion so no jab no job for me became
a crime against humanity and so the word
i used was deliberately in that context
i said i'm a conscientious objector
to vaccine mandates and will not be
taking one myself
and that was
you know
it reminded me what they then did to me
i mean it began a media campaign i was
called as you mentioned called all sorts
of things and it end ended with
it ended and culminated with in
chronological order a premature
termination of my contract on the
largest commercial
radio station in the uk with a show that
on the weekends was getting over half a
million listeners regularly during a
lunchtime slot on saturdays and sundays
and all of it was live
it was a beautiful
relationship with the public that was
terminated prematurely
over a moral objection now that in
hindsight those people should be ashamed
those people that came for me at that
moment in hindsight why should they be
ashamed because
we've now learned from the vaccine data
you go from let's start in in in
chronological order of the way in which
the dominoes fell let's start with
astrazeneca april last year when
astrazeneca themselves in the bbc
reports this admitted that under 30s
should not take their vaccine because of
blood clots
fine everyone started taking johnson
johnson moderna pfizer a week later
astrazeneca said uh-oh under 40
shouldn't take it either this is last
year right this year april moderna has
to recall thousands and thousands of
vials of their vaccine because direct
quote foreign contaminant is in the
vials right after that this month
johnson johnson gets restricted by the
cdc because another thing blood clots
the same thing keeps propping up again
and again blood clots the only one left
then became pfizer and as we know from
the data that's just been dumped because
a judge had to order them to release the
data as opposed to them wanting to after
75 years that data tells us that over 1
200 people
died
in the first three months of their trial
now
what i want to know is i don't
say that that's a causal link
there's a correlation there what i want
to know is how can you define consent if
i'm not informed of that correlation
yeah and uh you know it is not only
coercive it is a clear violation of
nuremberg right there are many things
about that that's why i said crime
against humanity it is a crime against
humanity and i would point out that
there are several insidious features
here right so on the one hand you have a
so-called vaccine and you and i have
just been at a conference where many
people uh made the point that actually
that definition is being so loosely used
here that it's it's counterproductive
but these so-called vaccines are
mysterious in their content and the idea
that people have in any way the
information with which to make an
informed choice is preposterous
but the other thing is that because of
these mandates
you have a violation of the idea that
you are obligated to reject immoral
orders right many people administered
these shots to people who they knew did
not have the information to make an
informed consensus and anybody who
didn't administer the shots who was in
those positions was very likely to lose
their jobs so
um that is
entirely disturbing it's two violations
of nuremberg right it's the immoral
orders uh portion and the informed
consent portion and then the consequence
of it i find even more terrifying but
i'm going to add
i'm going to add a point if i may yeah
so the violation isn't just by those
that perpetrated it and i believe you
this is neurabird level this is why i
use the words crime against humanity and
i said i became a conscientious objector
because this is war crime level stuff
and it's not just the perpetrators when
you start talking on that level and i'm
believe me i think we're there right
when you start talking on that level
anybody that propagated defended
supported
i was following orders no longer cuts it
when you're on that level of a crime it
doesn't cut it so anyone anyone that was
out there after being told this is the
problem and began hunting those that
were unvaccinated through their media
representations supporting things such
as lockdown only for the unvaccinated
supporting things like uh telling the
unvaccinated they cannot work
right that's a participation in the
crime and those people are also
responsible and it will not cut it to
say i was following orders yes the
coercion was insidious and it was
extremely broad it came in every form
from
interrupting your capacity to earn to
uh your social group being manipulated
into pressuring right
and um it's truly frightening in its own
right but i'm concerned actually
about what happens
one step down the road because what i
saw
was
a
what appears to me to be a very clever
move on the part of whatever this force
is that is that is doing these things in
which in one fell swoop they managed to
remove
all the people who were likely to object
right on the basis that those people
were going to object to their own
injections
of a substance that they didn't know
much about
that those people would eliminate
themselves from the ranks of our
security services of our military of our
universities and the problem is that
that leaves all of the institutions
in
basically staffed by people who don't
know that they are obligated to reject
immoral orders right that was that's a
genius level move and what it does is it
sets us up for the next tragedy of
history and i don't know what that
tragedy of history is going to look like
but i do know that we just got a lot
more likely to see it so i uh
i tweeted something related to what
you're just saying if i can read it and
then just uh i think because it links to
this point and then i can just tell you
what i was thinking when when i said
this
i i put this out yesterday so the the
optimum way to win this war against
humanity is to convince humans they are
not being warned upon
premium meat is wagyu the cow is
pampered until it is slaughtered
if you see but cannot perceive step
aside so that those of us who are awake
may fight this enemy for you i believe
the situation is that serious what you
just said there about staffing
institutions with people that no longer
have the uh the capacity to make moral
judgments and justify their actions by
following orders
you've got a situation that how you
create those people we have to be aware
that we're witnessing the creation of
that class
and so the cultural debates that are
happening in society at the moment
part of the
uh i'm going to summarize it in my
opinion part of the
how i see it is the deliberate
encouraging of narcissism in society so
that everybody is atomized right
it destroys community and if you destroy
community there's no way because a big
part of those moral judgments come from
community now i don't care what form
that community looks like it's why i'm
not anti-theist right it's why i'm not
anti-religion that community could be a
mosque it could be a synagogue it could
be a church equally it could be a yoga
center equally it could be a sikh temple
or a hindu temple it doesn't have to be
religious at all it could be the local
humanist chapter but that sense of
communities where people share moral
reflections and then and then find
solidarity in the communities more race
yeah that they go about sort of then
openly having the courage to speak about
that's how you get people that speak
because they feel they have a
moral sort of fabric supporting them
coming from their community if you don't
have that if you're atomized if you're
living in a shoebox in a city
you don't have the courage to speak
about anything you don't because you're
not connected to anything in the first
place the whole idea of speaking up
seems a very abstract notion for
somebody that is living in the
equivalent of a chicken in a cage right
which is the kind of architecture that's
now being encouraged in the kind of
architecture i've grown up through
london living in
and i think that so back to that point
about staffing these institutions
we have to we have to look
people in your position who who look at
things from a bird's-eye perspective
my view would be that we have to look
culturally at the entire scene and note
across
in an interdisciplinary way where
certain behavior patterns are
encouraging this problem of people
becoming unable or incapable of making
moral decisions for the betterment of
humanity and if that means as roger
scrutin used to do talking about
architecture but if that means you know
talking about holistic lifestyles or if
it means having this kind of more sort
of intellectual
uh conversation but ultimately we've got
to be aware of where this is happening
in multiple sectors because it's an
honor society problem in my view you
know and we've just witnessed how where
there's an order society failure look
what just happened i mean i i'm hoping
people agree with us by now it was a
failure
well
you know some do and some don't yet have
ears to hear or don't have the freedom
so what do you think is going on there
i think a number of things are going on
i mean i would say you're correct that a
kind of narcissism has been encouraged i
would also point to solipsism and
maybe most critically sophistry many of
the arguments that we are up against are
um
so obviously wrong but so difficult to
um
to dismantle that anyway we spin our
wheels explaining things that shouldn't
need any explanation
at all
[Music]